THERE IS NOT MUCH IN THE WAY OF
PROFESSIONAL ETHICES TO RESTRAIN
THEM FROM DOING THAT.
A LONG TIME BUSINESS PARTNER OF
PAUL MANAFORT.
THANKS FOR COMING.
ON.
WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
>> TO FORCE MANAFORT TO LEAD
GUILTY SO THE GOVERNMENT DIDN'T
HAVE TO GO TO TRIAL.
THE GOVERNMENT REFUSED TO TURN
NEVER ANY DISCOVERY DID
SURVEILLANCE TO PAUL MANAFORT.
THEY INSIST HE WAS NEVER UNDER
SURVEILLANCE BUT NUMEROUS
MAINSTREAM MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS
REPORTED OTHERWISE.
THAT'S BECAUSE HE WAS MOST
LIKELY SUBJECT TO AN ILLEGAL,
UNCONSTITUTIONAL FISA WARRANT.
I WAS ALSO SUBJECT TO THAT
REPORTED BY THE TIMES ON JANUARY
20th, 2016.
I JUST FILED A FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT REQUEST TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF THAT.
>> Tucker: IF THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" CAN DISCOVER YOU ARE
SPIED UPON BY THE GOVERNMENT,
WHY CAN'T YOU ASTERTAIN WHETHER
THAT'S HAPPENING?
>> THERE IS A PROCESS.
YOU HAVE TO PUT IN A
GOVERNMENTAL INFORMATION
REQUEST.
ONCE THE GOVERNMENT HAS HAD TIME
TO RESPOND, YOU CAN FILE A
LAWSUIT.
A TORT SUIT AND A SUIT AGAINST
INDIVIDUALS SAY JOHN BRENNAN AND
SUSAN RICE AND MR. CLAPPER.
TUCKER, IT'S CLEAR COMING UP
EMPTY HANDED OF ANY EVIDENCE OF
RUSSIAN COLLUSION OR ANY HIJINKS
WITH WIKI LINKS, THIS SPECIAL
COUNCIL WILL GO THROUGH EVERY
ASPECT OF MY LIFE TO CONJUROR UP
SOME OFFENSE TO PRESSURE ME TO
TESTIFY AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
IT'S THE POLICE STATE.
I AM BEING PERSECUTED BECAUSE I
SUPPORTED DONALD TRUMP.
>> Tucker: LET ME BACK UP.
WE ARE OFTEN TOLD THAT THE BAR
FOR A FISA WARRANT IS REALLY
HIGH.
YOU HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE SOMEONE
IS BETRAYING HIS COUNTRY.
WHAT WOULD BE THE CONTEXT ON
WHICH THE MUELLER PEOPLE GOT A
FISA WARRANT TO SPY ON YOU?
>> THE U.S. CITIZEN WITH ONLY BE
SUBJECTED TO A FISA WARRANT IF
THEY ARE ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
ESPIONAGE AGAINST THE UNITED
STATES.
FISA WARRANTS WERE USED BY THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES.
THIS IS A SCANDAL THAT MAKES
WATERGATE LOOK LIKE A SECOND
RATE BURGLARY.
>> Tucker: ARE THE PEOPLE AROUND
YOU DRAWN INTO THIS?
>> THAT'S THE EXTRAORDINARY
THING.
ASSOCIATES OF MINE HAVE BEEN
QUESTIONED AGGRESSIVELY BY THE
FBI.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
WANTS OTHER THAN TO FIND
SOMEBODY WHO WILL BEAR FALSE
WITNESS AGAINST ROGER STONE.
THIS IS COSTING ME HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS ON TOP OF
THE LAWSUITS FILED AGAINST ME BY
THE DEMOCRAT NATIONAL COMMITTEE
AND OBAMA-AFFILIATED GROUPS.
I HAD TO SET UP A LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND BECAUSE IT THREATENS TO
BANKRUPT ME WHICH IS THE POINT.
THEY SEEK TO DRAG YOUR NAME
THROUGH THE MUD AND RUIN YOU
FINANCIALLY.
>> Tucker: WE CAN'T ADMINISTRATE
A POLYGRAPH ON LIVE TELEVISION.
HAVE YOU EVER WORKED ON BEHALF
OF ANY FOREIGN POWER AGAINST THE
INTEREST OF THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT?
>> ABSOLUTELY, POSITIVELY NOT.
I AM AN AMERICAN WHOSE RELATIVES
WERE RUSHED IN BUDAPEST IN THE
'50s.
THIS IS AN ABSURD NOTION.
WE HAVE A PARTISAN SPECIAL